what's uh comes to mind as a
particularly beautiful thing that you're
proud of that you create inside
mathematica visualization wise or
something that just comes to memory if
it's possible to retrieve
so
the the thing i've spent the most
amount of time on
is i got obsessed um
a long time ago
was trying to tile
the globe with hexagons yes
and um
or an actual globe
well any spherical
okay object yeah but with an eye towards
uh putting it on the earth and so uh and
have it be recursive so
you can have hexagons within hexagons
which is hard because and probably a bad
idea because you can't
tile
a hexagon with smaller hexagons
don't they stick out
got it so they're oh they stick out so
there's a
can you do some kind of fractal hexagon
situation yeah yeah so so it's that and
people who who know me um are always uh
uh now now make fun of me for this so
they'll send me if they if they see
a picture with hexagons in it they'll
like send me a link you know to to
to make fun of me
um so as some one of those people roger
penrose or
i i think
roger's a little above my my level um
he's into hexagons as well and tiling
yeah yeah so um so i did a lot of that
and i thought you know it was pretty
cool
but um if there's some like surprisingly
intractable
problems that keep coming up like
you you've always got to have
some pentagons like if you start with a
icosahedron which is
equilateral triangles which is a logical
place to start
you can cover those with hexagons but
every
vertex where
uh where the
the triangles come together
is a pentagon has to be a pentagon
oh interesting so there's all hexagons
and then there's a pentagon at the
intersection yeah yeah cool how did you
figure that out is that a known fact
well it's just if you look at a yeah
like just by incidentally this thing got
it yeah so
so you can you can't make that go away
so
any system that you come up with to do
this has got to have
this
exceptions built into it for for those
12 you could have
quintillions of of hexagons
but you've still got to have 12
pentagons somewhere
um so um
so i've blown a hell of a lot of time on
on that over the years by the way
a lot of those kind of uh problems are
very difficult to prove something about
yeah
yeah
yeah
and i think uber did it because someone
one of my friends who uh
uh who who knows of my
my interest in this and who likes to
to give me a hard time
sent me a link this is a couple years
ago to
some
code base that i think came out of uber
where they had done this
you know you break break down the whole
surface of the earth into into little
hexagons
so um that was a real knife through the
heart
um
but
i'll probably come back to it
someday
is there something special about
hexagons are you interested in all kinds
of tiling
uh well
i'm interested in all kinds of tiling
but i'm not
i know my limitations like as a as a
math guy
so
hexagons are about my speed
um you know
just a sufficient amount of complexity
yeah
yeah
so but no tiling is a really interesting
problem both two and three dimensional
tiling problems are fascinating and
they're one of those ancient puzzles
that has
attracted
brainiacs for for centuries
you